Ciao a raggiungerle così Ah no ah ah il
mio amico Ho fame anch'io Guardate il
manager è arrabbiato perché non ci sono
nuovi clienti nel suo supermercato sta
guardando le camere di sicurezza e vede
che non ci sono nuovi clienti è
arrabbiatissimo ha tenuto un bottone
rosso di laser Beh ma come Ma così ne
arrivano ancora meno di clienti il
manager sta bloccando il supermercato
per cui tutti i clienti restano lì per
sempre
Ecco come va adesso a tenerli si
mangeranno tutto o meglio se c'hai un
cliente come me mi chiudi dentro al
supermercato io mi mangio tutto
meglio per il manager così compri tutto
e lui è contento
mangio e basta devi comprare per farlo
sei un supermercato non è che puoi
mangiare cose gratis
andiamo dai allora quindi c'è il manager
che è arrabbiato perché non ha più
clienti nel tuo supermercato faccio
chiuso qui con laser ci sta guardando
dalle camere di sicurezza e ha chiuso
dentro Così compriamo tutto secondo lui
compreremo tutto c'è una cassiera qui
Voglio andare a casa Sono così
non avevo visto
Sono così annoiato il manager è pazzo e
l'altro dice quello che direbbe sempre
Vitale ho fame
Andiamo
anch'io eri stanno prigionieri del
manager che hai fatto giusto qualcosa
che compriamo tutto sto andando dal mio
amico che ha fame così abbiamo fame in
due ragazzi Io mi metto dentro al
carrello
usciamo dal supermercato
Google Translate Allora qui abbiamo tipo
lasciate un mi piace se volete che
compro qualcosa con i Robot allora
no mi sono già sfracellato
sfracellamento di Vitale che bello Non
avevamo fatto ancora un Escape Room al
supermercato e io adoro esplorare tutto
al supermercato Infatti dei cereali
porcarella
[Musica]
Mi raccomando Non mangiarti tutto
cereali stavo vedendo quello che c'era
qui stiamo esplorando Qua ci sono I Rise
chips e qui ci sono dei distributori
vediamo se possiamo prendere qualcosa Ah
no questo posso salire sopra ma non
posso fare altro ma non fa cliccare
niente Ok allora qui in questo in questo
Eh beh in questo supermercato hanno
delle bottiglie di senape e di Ketchup
che sono giganti
e non si sa No forse per mangiare noi
forse alla fine il manager mangerà noi è
quello vero
da quella parte Guarda qua c'è un
negozio Shop Eh ci sono i saldi vediamo
che dice Ehi benvenuti nel mio negozio
vuoi guardare in tutto il mondo No non
voglio farmi guardare in tv Vabbè
diciamo di sfida
Ehi ma sono tutte cose carine No no no
Non compriamo proprio niente non c'è
qualcosa Grazie non c'è proprio niente
qui alla fine è un negozio quindi per
fortuna dobbiamo pagare Wow troppi
calorides andiamo in vacanza e non credo
che sia molto giusto siamo stati
imprigionati nel supermercato dal
Manager non possiamo andare in vacanza
adesso guarda cosa c'è dentro dei
personaggi tipo Greco questo cioccolato
Guarda cioccolato
fondente credo che queste siano ancora
delle salse vedi che ci sono le
bottiglie lì
dentro posso dire McDonald's ci sono i
donuts c'è la baguette Gigante Qui l'ha
detto non farti distrarre dal cibo
altrimenti ragazzi procederai più spesso
la panetteria questi sono oh oh il latte
scambiato Che messaggio è credo che
voglia dire che il latte è andato a male
Ah ah
ah trans bisogna andare qua Eh cerca di
non toccare il latte perché ho capito
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano pianissimo ci sono le taniche di
latte Queste sono sono da 25 litri
queste taniche di latte Guarda qua puoi
raggiungere
preferisco
Ho fame anch'io
potete allearvi e andare a
rubarcato
Guarda qua c'è un gelato misura XXL
e questo è fatto apposta per me allora
sì ma non puoi andare lì perché forse
dobbiamo passare su queste patatine
Ah dobbiamo evitarle patatine
[Musica]
le mie parti sfracellata e hanno salvato
vai attraverso la palestra della giungla
bellissimo
credo che dobbiamo passare qua Ok
passiamo da qui forse bisogna evitare
gli ostacoli che bello Sì
hai visto qui stavamo girando tra le
palline via via via
chi arriverà prima questa volta aiuto
arriverò prima Wow che figo perché
questi si può passare senza bisogno di
saltare Noi stavamo saltando Sul Segno
ostacoli quando in realtà potevamo
semplicemente passare aiuto tutto questo
Dai sbrigati Rita sono in vantaggio io 3
qua è troppo divertente questo gioco
voglio rimanere
ciao ciao ciao ciao No sono caduto Sto
ricominciando tutto da capo dove sei
caduto C'è un punto dove si può
scivolare e ti far tornare indietro
praticamente non ci credo adesso la
Anita in vantaggio Vedi ha fatto bene io
a fare tutto con calma dove c'è lo
scivolo là sopra che Ma come lo scivolo
ok Questo era un po' una freddura
Io vado Ciao
adesso non capisco aiuto
devi andare sopra Cioè devi andare nello
scivolo e poi cadrai qua posso scegliere
un pupazzo tu quale scegli di questi
aspetta oh che figo c'è
Non è il polipo e il calamaro non riesce
a parlare io si blocca l'amaro perché è
troppo carino mi serve il drago Che
bello anche l'ippopotamo mi piace però
purtroppo però dobbiamo andare avanti
dobbiamo scappare da manager
rispetto
Beh visto che siamo nella sezione frutta
Qual è il vostro frutto preferito
scriveteci nei commenti il vostro frutto
preferito il mio Va bene
strano che te lo sei ricordato Però mi
piacciono anche le ciliegie io le adoro
soprattutto le amarene Quindi qual è il
tuo frutto preferito invece Allora mi
piacciono Le clementine mi piacciono le
mele mi piacciono anche le ciliegie
sapete Ok la macedonia di frutta No io
ho scelto il mandarino andiamo nel libro
dice
Ah quindi stiamo andando nella libreria
Eh ma Ma dai sei un frutto scelgo la
parata Allora Ah pensavo le mele anche
le mele però la banana è più facile da
mangiare la banana siamo nella sezione
in libreria vediamo se c'è il mio libro
ma è un labirinto questa libreria però
credo che dobbiamo andare tutto dritto
qua no bisogna sbagliato
No è più difficile
è tutto il labirinto questa libreria Sì
no Anche qui è tutto pronto
ma dov'è la strada forse una trappola
del manager forse dobbiamo trovare un
libro ed entrare dentro un libro come
diceva lui all'inizio o forse no un
libro che aprirà sono riuscito a trovare
la via d'uscita come corri Non lo so
dove stai andando qui vieni Vieni dove
sei Sì guarda guarda
No vabbè
era un tranello
fighissimo Allora bisogna salire qua
sopra tipo
mi piace un sacco finora Sì Piano piano
piano piano piano piano piano
mantieni l'equilibrio non cadere laggiù
Quindi ancora in costruzione del
supermercato Siamo al piano di sopra
patatine
panini sì vai chiuso Mi dispiace
Io c'ho sempre fame Tranquilla sono qua
i panini guarda
saltiamo
credo che non sei caduto nella salsa
ancora
non sono scivolato Ok Salviamo Qua ci
sono
E allora Io torno indietro allora Ciao
ciao panini questo supermercato è più
grande è più un centro commerciale
Carrefour
La porta è chiusa Eh sì lo so Ci sono i
laser li vedo e quindi cosa dobbiamo
fare
scenderemo attraverso il salone di
conservazione il salone di conservazione
che cosa sarà il salone di conservazione
forse le celle le celle frigorifere Ah
quindi ci sarà altro cibo qua ma ci sarà
cibo caldo vediamo
nel frigo andremo nel frigo Sì ma è
tutto congelato Mi dispiace non puoi
mangiarlo Ma dove sto andando Oh no
perché non mi ha fatto salvare in tempo
quindi devo rifare tutto sto ancora
saltando no sulle magliette Eh io sono
un sacco in alto invece no dove c'è ci
sono tutti gli scatoloni e qua
sicuramente ci sarà un labirinto per
vita alta
sfracellato
giorni dopo è riuscito ad arrivare
un labirinto Vedi Era solo un passaggio
attento a questi ti sfracellano Ah sono
sempre più veloci
Ciao Cos'è questo è un alieno Ma cosa
c'entra Certo
che cosa vende questo questo alieno
verde dei barili e dei tappi di sughero
non è proprio quello che mi aspettavo
che vendesse un alieno
ci sono qui a destra se ci parli dice
Ehi vuoi comprare una mappa del
labirinto vuol dire che tra poco ci
aspetta un labirinto gigante io ho detto
sì no costa bravo Ciao allora E allora
vado da solo e sicuramente sarà
difficili Allora Ah questo è il
labirinto quasi una freccia adesso c'è
la freccia Allora dai Strano però che
l'hanno reso così facile
ci sta portando verso il mostro qua c'è
un'altra freccia
Chi ha creato questo gioco si è reso
conto che era troppo difficile Aiuto
aiuto Ah ecco mi ha detto
Invece altrimenti non usciranno mai
[Musica]
Aspetta ma ci hanno ci hanno mangiato Ok
così facile
manager altra porta chiusa Eh sì dove
dobbiamo passare adesso Oh no nella
cella
la cella frigorifera
ci concentreremo pure noi Ok allora
forse qui dobbiamo essere veloci vediamo
Non lo so perché ma sento freddo davvero
freddo
[Risate]
l'altra scatola attenta perché qui
allagato Ehi Però è stato abbastanza
facile adesso
sì Stiamo uscendo dal frigo Oh che
freddo
qui ci sono i laser attenta che questi
laser ci fanno prendere fuoco però
passiamo dal freddo al caldo ehi forse
stiamo simpatici al manager perché tu
sono inceppato pensavo di stare andando
nella direzione giusta invece stavo
tanto in quella sbagliata no
Ti vuoi comprare tutto da mangiare
quindi il manager ha detto Guarda che
bello farò un quiz Stiamo andando nel
suo ufficio
Sei riuscito a entrare
Ok Visto che passavi dalla porta questo
è un altro magazzino siamo ancora nei
magazzini del supermercato
[Musica]
stai facendo Ti sei spregelata
si riesce a vedere che è tipo un
labirinto coi laser c'è anche qualcuno
che ci aspetta Chi sarà mai quello
Laggiù e il nostro amico il nostro amico
dai andiamo possiamo trovarci perché le
persone che stanno lavorando al
supermercato anche loro vogliono
scappare dal manager che li vuole
rinchiudere dentro per sempre Francesco
brava ma non possiamo prendere questo
trattore Io ci provo purtroppo
così almeno facciamo insieme ma tu
Ultimamente stai sempre vincendo in
Belgio questa volta voglio vincerli
prima io voglio arrivare prima io
sfracellato dietro di te Ah ah ah
Non riesco a capire come come faccio a
presentarvi così tante volte con questi
laser Salvo subito ok Io ho saltato
Vediamo se Vitale ce la fa Dov'è Eccomi
sono qui sono qui forse ce la faccio
Ah eccolo
ultimo ultimo ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta a salvare Subito
andiamo a parlare con il nostro amico
vediamo un po' difficile Oh Amico oh no
ho sbagliato aspetta aspetta
attraverso l'uscita
abbiamo finito dici Non lo so se siamo
riusciti a scappare
Ah qui c'è una porta aperta vedi Ah ma
io non sono andato di là
e siamo davvero riuscita io non sono
riuscito Aspettami
Sbrigati c'è la porta scendendo
Questa è la parte dove stanno lanciando
la frutta vedi Ah ma prima la stavano
lanciando non hai visto muoversi Ehi
state rovinato i vetri ci sono le
macchine qui parcheggiate quindi forse
c'è
adesso dice di cliccare qua Ah dobbiamo
prendere il drink veloce corrisci
corri corri corri
Che figo Io adoro la super velocità sì
Salviamo e ho preso
niente Ce l'abbiamo fatta hanno
arrestato il manager Guardate Wow
ora usa una utilizzare le tappe verdi
per giocare più giochi di divertimento
come questo Molto bene grazie vediamo
Guarda il manager
ottieni giù
Volevo solo più clienti poverini sì ce
l'abbiamo fatta scappare dal manager
cattivo fa un po' pena però che l'hanno
arrestato lui voleva solo più clienti
vediamo se riusciamo a entrare No quella
macchina della polizia nella base della
polizia
Ma perché questi poliziotti sono
talmente tanto alti e le macchinine con
cui sono arrivati sono talmente tanto
piccole e infatti non ci entrano là
dentro Forse perché Ah sono arrivato con
l'elicottero Guarda guarda
Eh forse dobbiamo no
pizza come fame non fa andare qua dove
c'è la pizza quindi giusto per niente
giusto quindi è tutto finito bene il
manager è stato arrestato Noi abbiamo
preso il badge ce l'abbiamo fatta yeah
lasciate un bel mi piace Ora vi lasciamo
qui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video
eh Buona visione Ciao